The relationship between the United States and China is tense.
Really tense.
Especially when it comes to trade.
It wasn’t always this way.
Decades ago, the United States supported China’s
economic opening, lifting millions of
its people out of poverty.
This created a huge labor force that helped
make China one of the world’s leading manufacturers
of everything from electronics to clothing, to steel.
China’s economic boom was good for the U.S. too.
It provided cheap goods for American consumers.
And it became a massive marketplace for American
soybeans, cars, and many other products.
There were issues, though.
When China joined the World Trade Organization
in 2001, it promised to lower trade barriers
and make its markets fairer for foreign companies.
The United States and many other countries
now say China has failed to live up to those promises.
They believe China’s approach to trade violates
international rules and even threatens the
global economic system.
So just how bad are China’s trade practices?
There are big concerns.
China makes it incredibly difficult for outside
companies to do business there.
The government favors its own firms by giving
them billions of dollars in subsidies.
This allows them to export their products
at artificially low prices.
Consumers around the world then buy
these cheap Chinese products instead of local products.
This drives China’s competitors out of business.
The government also doesn’t always enforce
basic legal protections for foreign companies operating in China
And even if it did enforce the rules, many
find them unfair to outsiders.
For instance, foreign firms have often had to create joint ventures with local companies to enter China.
In this “partnership,” the foreign firm
is forced to share its technology with the Chinese firm.
This allows the Chinese company to acquire
new technology without paying for it.
In other cases, Chinese companies straight-up
steal intellectual property.
They have hacked into American computers to
access trade secrets, like blueprints for
a robot used in T-Mobile labs and driverless
car technology from Apple.
They then use these plans to counterfeit versions
of American products.
U.S. officials believe the Chinese government
is behind these types of cyber espionage.
And in the past, the Chinese government has kept its currency weak, giving its exports an added leg up.
Now, none of these complaints are new.
And it’s not just President Donald Trump
who’s attempted to bring China in line.
Both Democrats and Republicans have pushed
back against China’s trade practices.
The Obama administration tried to get Beijing to do more to stop cyberattacks and intellectual property theft.
And in 2015, the two sides reached a deal
to do just that.
Both Obama and Trump have used executive powers
to block deals between U.S. and Chinese firms
that might endanger national security.
And they both took complaints to the World
Trade Organization.
Trump has also imposed lots of tariffs on
Chinese goods.
So has any of it worked?
China has made some changes, but major economic
conflicts still remain.
And that’s not even mentioning other security
and human rights concerns about China.
Things like censoring the internet.
And monitoring its citizens.
Detaining hundreds of thousands of Uighur Muslims.
And curbing freedoms in Hong Kong.
The list goes on and on.
U.S. officials and other experts had hoped
that China’s economic success would lead
it to become more democratic.
But clearly, that has not happened.
And getting China to play fair on trade might
not happen either.